what is the Pearson correlation the
Pearson correlation analyzes the
relationship between two variables for
example is there a relationship between
a person's salary and age in the scatter
plot every single point is a person if
the relationship is confirmed in this
example salary can be predicted by age
using a regression but beware it's not
always that easy there must be a clear
causal relationship for this just
because there is a correlation you can't
tell which way the relationship is going
so with the help of Pearson correlation
we can measure the linear relationship
between two variables here we can
determine how strong the correlation is
and in which direction the correlation
goes we can read both in the Pearson
correlation coefficient R which is
between -1 and 1. the strength of the
car correlation can be read in a table
if R is between 0 and 0.1 we speak of no
correlation if R is between 0.7 and 1 we
speak of a very strong correlation a
positive correlation exists when large
values of one variable go along with
large values of the other variable or
when small values of one variable go
along with small values of the other
variable a positive correlation is found
for example for body size and shoe size
the result is a positive correlation
coefficient a negative correlation
exists when large values of one variable
go along with small values of the other
variable and vice versa a negative
correlation usually exists between
product price and sales volume the
result is a negative correlation
coefficient how is the Pearson
correlation calculated the Pearson
correlation coefficient is obtained via
this equation where R is the Pearson
correlation coefficient x i are the
individual values of one variable each
y i are the individual values of the
other variable EG salary and x dash and
Y dash are respectively the mean values
of the two variables in the equation we
can see that the respective mean value
is first subtracted from both variables
so in our example we calculate the mean
values of age and salary we then
subtract the mean values from each
person's age and salary
we then multiply both values then we sum
up the individual results of the
multiplication the expression in the
denominator ensures that the correlation
coefficient is scaled between
-1 and 1. if we now multiply two
positive values we get a positive value
so all values that lie in this area have
a positive influence on the correlation
coefficient if we multiply two negative
values we also get a positive value
minus times minus is plus so all values
that lie in this area also have a
positive influence on the correlation
coefficient
if we multiply a positive value and a
negative value we get a negative value
minus times plus is minus so all values
that lie in these ranges have a negative
influence on the correlation coefficient
therefore if our values are
predominantly in these two areas we get
a positive correlation coefficient and
thus a positive relationship if our
values are predominantly in these two
areas we get a negative correlation
coefficient and thus a negative
relationship if the pawns are
distributed over all four areas the
positive terms and the negative terms
cancel each other out and we get a very
small or no correlation but now there is
one more thing to consider the
correlation coefficient is usually
calculated with data taken from a sample
however we often want to test a
hypothesis about the population in the
case of a correlation analysis we then
want to know if there is a correlation
in the population for this we check
whether the correlation coefficient in
the sample is statistically
significantly different from zero the
null hypothesis in the Pearson
correlation is the correlation
coefficient does not differ
significantly from zero there is no
linear relationship and the alternative
hypothesis is the correlation
coefficient differs significantly from
zero there is a linear relationship
attention it is always tested whether
the null hypothesis is rejected or not
in our example we could have the
research question is there a correlation
between age and salary in the British
population to find out we draw a sample
and test whether in this sample the
correlation coefficient is significantly
different from zero the null hypothesis
then is there is no correlation between
salary and age in the British population
and the alternative hypothesis there is
a correlation between salary and age in
the British population whether the
correlation coefficient is significantly
different from zero based on the sample
collected can be checked using a t-test
where R is the correlation coefficient
and N is the sample size
a p-value can then be calculated from
the test statistic T if the p-value is
less than the specified significance
level which is usually five percent then
the null hypothesis is rejected
otherwise it is not but what about the
assumptions for appears in correlation
here we must distinguish whether we just
want to calculate the Pearson
correlation coefficient or whether we
want to test a hypothesis to calculate
the Pearson correlation coefficient only
two Matrix variables need to be present
Matrix variables are for example a
person's weight a person's salary or
electricity consumption the Pearson
correlation coefficient then tells us
how large the linear relationship is if
there is a non-linear relationship we
cannot tell from the Pearson correlation
coefficient however if we want to test
whether the Pearson correlation
coefficient is significantly different
from zero the two variables must also be
normally distributed if this is not
given the calculated test statistic t or
the p-value cannot be interpreted
reliably if you like you can of course
calculate a correlation analysis online
with data tab just copy your data into
this table and click on the hypothesis
or correlation tab if you now click on
the two Matrix variables appears in
correlation will be calculated
automatically
if you don't know exactly how to
interpret the results you can also just
click on summary in words
I hope you enjoyed the video and see you
next time